estera peral is a psychotherapist and
international advisor on sex and
relationships
that oprah winfrey called one of the
hundred most influential people in the
world
she went from growing up in belgium with
holocaust survivors to being a highly
paid psychotherapist who helps people
move from
not being dead to being truly alive
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
estara perel and my take on her top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one take responsibility
as you've worked with all different
people through these relationships
is there a sort of like common mark or
common marks of
successful relationships yeah come up
time and time again
yeah yeah yeah you know i'm a couples
therapist
and i don't know if you know but in
couples therapy rarely do people come to
tell you what they have done wrong
they don't really come to tell you
what's the matter with them they come to
a drop-off center
and they come to tell me this is my
partner you know i will be the expert on
what's wrong with that person
and fix it um i think by definition
relationships that do well
are relationships where people take
responsibility for their share
without being mired in shame for it
and it's so it's safe to take
responsibility
safe to own your stuff and people have a
sense that
you know if you want to change the other
you change yourself
rule number two aim high i always had a
clear sense that my life was not going
to be small
sure my life has to be big big doesn't
mean successful and money big meant
meaningful rich layered you know
it's not necessarily well known or
famous but
feeling fruitful yeah not dead not dead
i mean
there's a reason i write about eroticism
right and
that sense that i was not going to be
mediocre
you know i'm not content with just the
average of something that it has to be
not the best it has to be the right one
for me at that moment that may be the
beautiful spot or the
the right friend to be with or or the
right act to take in relation to
somebody or to some cause but
that sense that my life has to be big
rule number three
define infidelity for yourself the
interesting thing is that it's not
because you don't talk about something
that it doesn't exist
and if i go and i ask audiences all over
the world for the past
since 2009 now that i began the research
on this book
how many of you have been affected by
the experience of infidelity
about 80 of the people raised their hand
and that means that they were the
children of parents who were unfaithful
or the way the children who were born in
an affair
in a love story really or they were the
siblings or they were the friend that
was consoling
a broken heart or they were the friends
that was listening
to the confidences of someone who's in
the trolls of an affair
or they are the third in the triangle
it is systemic but the topic of
infidelity which has been
historically condemned is historically
practiced
shrouded in secrecy and shame and hence
kept very very silent
and unfortunately not helpful to the
thousands of people
who grapple with it so i've spent the
last
years working with hundreds of couples
who've been shattered by the experience
of an affair and of infidelity in the us
and abroad and i thought we can do
better
so what's what's the definition of
infidelity then or how should we be
defining it is it thinking about
being with other people is it flirting
is it
what's the line what's the boundary
what's the definition so
the definition keeps on expanding that's
the first thing
it is no longer just because you got
pregnant from somebody else
with contraception today the definition
has become
is it watching porn is it chatting
is it a massage with happy endings
is it staying active on your dating apps
when you're already seeing somebody more
steadily
is it reconnecting with your exes on
facebook
it is actually rather unclear and it is
often left to the people to define it
but there are three major elements that
i think make it very
clearer for me anyway to define it the
first thing is that it
usually is organized around the secret
the constitutive element of infidelity
is the secrecy
when it's not a secret when it's
consensual there it's a completely
different story so the secret is at the
heart of infidelity
so when your partner doesn't know or
isn't aware that's right
then yes and of course that today
requires you to ask what must be shared
and what is private
what is the extent between privacy
secrecy and transparency
then the second element is a certain
kind of emotional involvement
to one degree or another even if it's
hit and run
there still is an emotional involvement
it takes effort to make something mean
nothing
right yeah so the the quality of that
involvement
with the person with the sex with the
feelings that and then the third one
which is really the most important one
is that it's a sexual
alchemy the element of sexual alchemy is
not
sex we know that most affairs are way
less about sex and a lot more about
desire
now desire for what desire to be desired
desire to be seen to feel important to
have someone's attention
someone who cares about you desire to
feel alive decided to reconnect with
lost parts of yourself
way more important than the sex itself
the kiss that you only imagine giving
can be just as powerful as hours of
actual lovemaking
the mind is the most important sexual
organ
these treating secrecy emotional
involvement
sexual alchemy intersecting with each
other
are the three central elements of what
makes infidelity
but today that we don't have religious
institutions necessarily
telling us what is the king of sins it
is left to us
and our relationships to make sense of
this to define it to know where our
lines will be with our partners to know
when we cross those lines and if it's
about
thinking if it's about remembering it's
about fantasizing while you're with your
partner if it's
it is a subject that is
deeply entrenched in our lives and often
very difficult for us
to to open up and yet
we need to because because we need to
help people
who suffer with it rule number four look
for decency in people
my father was illiterate okay my father
and my mother actually both of them came
to belgium
by chance after each of them being four
and five years in concentration camps
in poland uh they both were the sole
survivors of their entire
family they came with absolutely nothing
they were illegal refugees
for five years before they even became
legalized
and my father always was a person who
said it doesn't matter
how brilliant they are or how rich they
are
what matters the most is how decent they
are
and when you are in a concentration camp
you get to see
the limits of a person's humanity and
the stretch
and the outreach of a person's humanity
and their decency and for some reason
that always stayed with me
meaning don't get impressed by all the
appearances and by how everything looks
look at the person
and then he said and a friend is the
person who will always do more for
themselves as they
for the other sorry as they will do for
themselves that's your friend
and check people out on that basis and
he had never read a book
he couldn't read and write pretty much
he read the newspaper he spoke five
languages but poorly
and and he was a grand human being and i
often often think of him in relation to
that especially when i come into
the entrepreneurial world which is often
a world of inflated selves
also if you want more confidence and
motivation check out my 254 series where
every day for 254 days i send you an
amazing unlisted video via email for
free the links to join on the
description below
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be
because being a really really good
listener is one of the most underrated
secrets to success
so what you're going to have to do is
you're gonna basically get bounced
around a lot
all over the place rule number five seek
positive changes
there is a phenomenal crossing of
parallel tracks that is happening
currently
on the one hand a matching set of
expectations you know when you come to
personal life romantic life
the expectations that you would have
with one person what once an entire
community used to provide
the same person is going to give us
security and stability
and dependability and reliability and
predictability
and the same person is going to give us
awe and mystery and passion and novelty
and excitement and
danger and fill in the bucket
this dual set of needs like that that
you know for most of history marriage
was for survival
then we brought in the companionship
romantic element and now we want
relationships for self-actualization
well the same thing is happening at work
you know you don't just and
you know you go to work and you don't
plan to spend 20 years there and work
your way up
step by step you know the wall street
journal had an article
i just read yesterday it was called
quitters are winners it's like the more
you leave the faster you grow
kind of thing and the more you're going
to get better jobs and this notion that
after two years
something has to happen and if you you
know used to say that
you live you left marriages if you were
very unhappy and today you leave them if
you think you could be happier
but the same thing happens with the job
you don't leave the job
you know because they close the factory
you leave the job because you don't feel
that you have been promoted properly and
fast enough
and that rising on the maslow ladder of
needs
you know that notion that it's about
self-actualization
about identity formation about belonging
the fact that we bring to love market
economy and we talk about having a good
deal in our relationships
but we bring two relations to work a
language and a vocabulary of
relationships we talk about authenticity
belonging empathy trust when was that
the bottom line language
of business rule number six regulate
yourself
trust is something that gets cultivated
over time through tests and experiences
together with other people
of course this has changed because we
have a shared economy in which we are
trusting total strangers with our home
and our most precious belongings
so the whole definition of trust is
shifting but it's difficult to have a
feeling of belonging when you don't stay
long enough
or to have a feeling of belonging when
you're hired by the day and by the hour
because it suits the numbers of the
company
and every book these days about
relationships is going to talk about
belonging
or the lack thereof and about loneliness
or the isolation and the lack of
connection
this is the two main subjects that
everybody is talking about
partly because when you dismantle a
system
like the one that we had and you
introduce a new social system
you can become evangelical about it you
can be very happy about all the changes
but you have to deal with the
consequences of the changes
and one of the things that dan siegel
was talking about so beautifully
yesterday
is that an individual a body a society a
relationship
needs to regulate itself and one of the
main thing we regulate ourselves on
is between stability and change
between chaos and rigidity between the
past
and the future when we have too much
change going on all at once
we become ontologically anxious or
anguished
because we can't catch up which is
partly what is happening now and what
has been
propelled in the last year by the new
president of this country
and by the new presidents of a bunch of
other countries and by the metoo
movement
it's a unique educational opportunity
but it makes a lot of people very
nervous rule number seven
own your mistakes there's only two
relationships
that resemble each other the one you
have with your parents
or the people who raise you and the one
you have with the people
you fall in love with people can sit in
my office
all the time and say i have this with no
one else i don't have this with anybody
at work
nobody among my friends ever thinks like
that you're the only one who speaks like
this or thinks this about me or with
whom i do this
no you're the only one and now we go
back in history
and i'm sorry to be the psychologist but
that's really
it is the place where we often learned
about closeness
trust loyalty commitment sharing
taking receiving asking all these
essential verbs of relationships we
learned that at home
we also learned jealousy and
possessiveness vengeance
you name them the beauty and the not
beauty yeah we saw it all as children
right we saw the fights we saw the love
we saw the
you know we saw the coldness the lack of
intimacy the intimacy yes
yes and we bring that with us and we
often promise ourselves i'll never be
this one
i'll never be this way i'll never talk
like this i'll
you know and we find ourselves often
much
closer to the apple and then presenting
ourselves
to the tree we resent ourselves we're
like how do we do that well why don't we
get to this place and then we feel
ashamed about it
and since we don't like to feel ashamed
about it we hide it
and one of the way we hide it is we
blame the partner
that's just one of the ways there's a
lot we are very resourceful in not
owning our [ __ ]
rule number eight find a mentor stand up
if you if you have been blessed by
having a mentor
in the realm of relationships
wow nice nice because i don't want to
ask if you've had mentors in your
business lives because
everybody will be standing this inequity
between having models for how you do
business
but not having enough models for how you
live your relationships
needs to change it really is
foundational
and i you know some of you it may be
your parents and some of you it may be
the neighbor and some of you it may be
somebody that you actually never even
met
but it is absolutely clear that having a
mentor in the realm of relationship
is essential for people to have
something that they can aspire to and
emulate
so take a moment for those of you who
stand and thank them
and then make also mental note if you
actually have ever told them
and if you haven't it's a good idea and
don't wait till they're on their dead
bed
and if you don't then just ask yourself
who who could you reach out to who would
be someone
to whom you could talk about that part
of your life it is not okay
that therapists like me are often the
only
people to hear the stories and the truth
and especially now it's fake news on
social media where
everybody has to parade their joyous
happy lives
nobody has any idea of what's happening
in the lives of others
your best friends can come and break up
and you didn't even see it coming
rule number nine have courage and then
when there is a crisis when something
breaks out suddenly
people launch into conversations that
they've never had and they are finally
grappling with a level of honesty about
this
but in the midst of so much pain that
resentment
anger yeah confusion pain rage
disappointment
romantic frustration you name it like
could we do better can we do it sooner
can we
have the courage to have some of the
difficult conversations before we're in
the midst of a crisis
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is ask yourself questions you make a
quick
note to yourself what's one thing that
you need to do at least before you see
me again
meaning you have a year it's a long time
my patience they have a week
you know or they have to tell me by 36
hours
i did x or i did why you know what
is one thing that you could do
concretely that doesn't have to be
qualified and excused and defended and
and explained the way that would bring a
different balance
to where you put the best parts of you
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that if you're still here
watching and you promise you commit
that you're gonna take action after
watching this video you're not just
gonna watch a video you're gonna do
something afterwards give me a hashtag
but leave in the comments because i want
to celebrate
you it's important to have a sense of
how how do we map relationships i think
sometimes the word is kind of mystifying
and in fact relationships are quite
structured systems you know in which you
straddle
two main axes structure
hierarchy power discipline um
all the way down to chaos and
relatedness
from very close to very far distant and
disengaged
pretty much most relationships can be
tracked there but now you take your team
and you look
how are we working here is this a very
hierarchical very
set system nothing can happen you have
to go through 10 different people
change is impossible etc etc but it's
very warm
because we have a lot of closeness and
it it's camaraderie
but very inefficient or is it very
distant rather cold
but actually very structured and very
efficient but not very loving
you can map that and then you begin to
see what are
the attributes that we have ample of
and what are the ones that need to be
reinforced and
who can do that who can bring the pieces
that the other people
may not necessarily have so that you
create a
real diversity that isn't only
about gender and race and background but
it is actually about relational
capacities
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there